yeah okay all right so this position
looks like an IED or gone very wrong for
black white sacrificed a piece I think
that I would much prefer to be white
here because there are a lot of great
attacking opportunities when you plan
tournaments to use usually score with
the consistent result to perform on the
extremes I I used to be on the extremes
but nowadays I tend to be much more
stable which probably is going to give
me a result that's you know bit
different than would have been a few
years ago so I tend to be pretty
consistent okay so this looks like a
shish knock off Sicilian um if I had to
look at the solution since I don't like
playing the Shiva Shankar that much with
black anymore I think that I much prefer
the white side of this I'm perhaps a bit
too positionally these days but that's
how it goes so I would say that black
has given up a lot given up giving up
this critical score on d5 and I'm much
what I would prefer to be white alright
so um let's see well obviously with
shaving is closer to the truth can can
mean many things but my level it's very
important that I try and play my best in
every single game so it's definitely
going to be a I bring my I don't really
know it's my opponent sorry Black has
just played g5 your first instinct is to
well in this position I think it depends
whether I'm playing a classical game
against a top player or whether I'm
playing a blitz or bullet game if I was
playing blitz or bullet I think there's
probably about a 95% chance that I would
sack on g5 in a classical game I would
go Bishop g3 so I'm gonna have to be
it's this on what I would do in a
serious classical game of chess which
would be to retreat the bishop to g3
which I know means that I'm not going to
be a barbarian okay do you play gambits
um I used to play a lot of gambits now
nowadays I tend to play perhaps a bit
too classically so the answer is going
to be no I don't play gambits these days
because they don't work against the top
players
all right how would you think about
whether or not to take on g5 all right
here I think I would evaluate it based
on two things I think that it depends
largely whether after you sacrifice on
g5 you can play 'if the pawn from e3 to
e4 and swing the rook over or not um if
I don't see a good way to stop that then
I would definitely sacrifice so I think
it's going to be AI would evaluate the
place where the pieces are more
specifically the rook on c3 under
serious time pressure you're more likely
to miss a tactic or move pieces
aimlessly I think it's easily a I I mean
at my level you always have to have some
idea of what you're doing you can't just
make random moves so it's going to be a
mess a tactic which of these ideas do
you prefer for white trade the bishop
would put a knight on d4 or push d4 on
oh and this in this position I think it
requires a little bit of time to think
but my first instinct would be to push
the pawn to d4 or force the bishop away
and head-on go go straight on ahead with
a5 and attack so the answer is going to
be B you start the game out with one d4
would you rather your opponent play one
d5 or one off five 100% or prefer that
my opponent plays f5 both because it's
not the best move and also because I
like more exciting positions than things
that are going to be symmetrical and dry
so B you have been ahead of pawn for
most the game but after tough resistance
from your opponent you only five minutes
left in the position you should plan or
offer a draw well you have an extra pawn
there's no risk of losing so I'm
offering a draw would just be really
quite stupid frankly I mean at the very
least you can get down to five seconds
and offer a draw but not playing all in
this position as a you know the wrong
wrong decision by a mile so you have to
keep pushing and trying to win which
statement comes closest to your feelings
let's see so it's always a joy to be
paired with someone you've crushed or
the odds of winning are slightly higher
against opponents one has beaten on I
think the answer is obviously for me
going to be a I always enjoy playing
against people who I've dominated in the
past and there are a few people at the
top who I have quite
good results against and anytime we get
to play them with white I'm always very
happy so the answer is a with plenty of
time on the clock what would you do in
this position trade on e6 and then the
work to 7th or invest some serious time
well I would probably use one second and
take take the vishanti six simply
because in this position it's too
simplified so no other moves really make
much sense and whether it was in
classical or in blitz or bullet I would
just take right away so the answer is a
what do you think of the famous a famous
saying
chess is 99% tactics I don't agree at
all I think it's much lower I think up
to about 2,400 level which is
International Master it's probably about
90 95 % but beyond that that goes down
to maybe 50% I would say so the answer
is B I disagree how do you feel about
this wild gambit line for black um well
it's pretty obvious this is ridiculously
unsound you're completely losing on
you'd have to be out of your mind to
play this way so yeah the answer is a no
way I mean it's it's stupid to play like
this after losing a game have you ever
broken something or yelled out loud I'd
like to say the answer is a um of course
that is absolutely not true I've I think
I've done both um it doesn't say well
this refers to classical chess or online
but if we're talking about online I
definitely use some some inappropriate
language and I have also slammed my
mouse and thrown against the wall a few
times so the answer is is B yes I have
unfortunately done both wait - playing
Castle okay in this position it looks
some pretty normal again I think this
depends whether it's going to be a
classical game chess or blitz game and
blitz or bullet I think it's about 85 90
% that I would castlelong in a classical
game of chess most likely I would Castle
short here because in in a classical
game I probably would notice the block
is going to have some Knight h5 ideas
and the attack is going to be quite as
strong but
so it depends what I'm playing but I'm
going to base this on classical trust so
the answer would be a kingside which is
closer to the truth
I get excited or nervous or I don't
worry about prizes money titles or
honors at this point in my career that
the answer is definitely going to be B
because I've played in so many
tournaments I've had so much experience
that it's not particularly relevant to
me whether I you know make a lot of
money win a tournament or or you know
getting a title it's more important to
play good chess so the answer is B but I
would say for probably the first three
to four years of my chest career the
answer would have been a but for now
it's B how would you come up with a plan
in this position that's white I think
I've actually seen this position before
I think I'm pretty sure this is theory
this position I probably would not think
very much I would just take right away
on d5 because ii v is looks positionally
wrong and he takes off v also should
should be beneficial to black so I would
just take on d5 right away which means I
would definitely go for a for B I would
calculate some lines and just just make
a move which is harder for you to do
identify advantages and build a plan or
trade a good position for a strong
attack I think at this point it's
definitely me B because when you get a
good position it's hard to go for
something which could potentially be
speculative I mean it depends how strong
the attack is but if it isn't clear and
completely straightforward it is quite
hard to trade those two advantages and
the answer is I am NOT a barbarian I
apparently I'm a technician which is
kind of kind of strange
clearly Danny when he made this
personality the chess personality quiz
he he clearly didn't understand what
kind of a chess player I am so I'm gonna
blame Danny for thinking I'm some crazy
barbarian but apparently I played trust
like Kramnik kind of maybe I'm not sure
all right well I hope you enjoyed seeing
me take this chest personality quiz on
chess comm and until next time